so why I'm Sandler is making a new movie
let's do this it's not fake it's not
apple juice
it's Rael so that's my boys the new
movie starring Adam Sandler and I was
like uh man in fact so much so I was
like let's do this yeah I don't make
those interests for nothing so when Adam
Sandler was in junior high he had sex
with his teacher a really hot teacher
too after that she gets knocked up he
becomes really famous people give him
like TV deals to tell the story and now
27 years later Adam Sandler's all grown
up he's washed up he has not a dollar to
his name in his son who's Andy Samberg
wants nothing to do with him he hasn't
seen him in years now Samberg is getting
married and Adam Sandler finds out about
it and so he just goes there and it's
not as good as wedding crashers if
that's what you're thinking but yeah he
really kind of crashes the whole thing
another reconnecting father-son Adam
Sandler's a slob and you know vanilla
eyes are so is the movie funny it's a
lot funnier than a lot of his recent
movies I will be honest with you some
parts of this I was like this is
hilarious I love this they were dumb but
I laughed my ass off I'm not above
laughing at some dumb [ __ ] as long as it
has an element of hey figure it out for
yourself we're not going for runs just
for the sake of raunch if funny happens
to be raunchy I can roll with that if
it's just raunchy for the sake of being
raunchy because they want it to be rated
R it's just not funny you don't have to
use your brain with it come on this
movie had boat it had some dumb funny
that was just really hilarious and then
I had other just wrong [ __ ] that just
maybe want to shoot myself in the face I
mean I suppose funny is subjective but
I'm just saying if they were like oh hey
all those funny moments we're going to
keep and we're gonna make more moments
like that they could have had like a
modern-day wedding crashers or something
in the end we have an Adam Sandler movie
that's just funnier than a lot of his
recent movies another point Adam
Sandler's voice in this movie yeah
that's all I really have to say about
that's all I need to say about I
understand he's doing an Adam Sandler
voice but it's one of those voices it's
like hey madam Shin I'm like a jerk like
yes you know he sounds like a really bad
Peter Griffin impersonation I don't sell
the movie once but I'm pretty sure
that's how I remember it
his voice is like two cats who were
screwing at midnight right outside your
window and you need to sleep and you
can't yeah it's all like
stopping dude seriously stop ID are you
not worn out by now I would be in
sausage stir I thought it was for me but
like I said there were quite a few
moments in this movie roles like that's
funny some of them are the pop-culture
references some of them were the cameos
in this movie and I a some mindless [ __ ]
oh hey some other jokes that are
actually funny ah some more mindless
[ __ ] the mindless [ __ ] is just ripping
in the movie down I got to think that
their mindset as well if people like our
stupid-ass movies because people watch
our stupid-ass movies so we make more
stupid-ass movies and the paradox and
the problem is as long as people pay to
see their stupid-ass movies they're
never going to be like oh people aren't
watching our stuff anymore so we should
make really funny movies so people watch
them it's not as bad as Jack and Jill
for sure in fact it's a lot better than
a lot of his movies in the past few
years I will say that's my boy is a good
time if you're drunk and now is a party
Gentry's leave the best part of the
movie for me was the setup in which you
see the teacher is that one chick who
susan sarandon daughter in real life
might have seen her in Californication
seriously dude dude I genuinely have not
wanted a wine cooler so badly in my
entire life as I do right now a lot of
people ask me like oh you trying to
break into Hollywood I don't feel I need
to break into Hollywood II I am doing
well right now but I would break into
Hollywood just so I could meet her drive
a wedge in between her and her husband
and split the two apart take her for
myself I've mean it I mean it
that's right chivalry's not dead while
I'm breathing I'm a romantic like that
so what's your favorite Adam Sandler
cameo in a movie not Adam Sandler cameo
in a movie but you know how his movies
always have weird cameos like Bob Barker
and happy gilmore you're like Oh awesome
so yeah we're gonna ask that in any case
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
oh it's up my nose